Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwood's Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with some important information
about the war against the freedom of
speech which may be the most important
war in which we are embroiled today and
yet one that few Americans realize is
even being fought David Petraeus the
former director of the CIA and former
commander of centcom recently published
a piece in the Washington Post entitled
anti-muslim bigotry AIDS Islam islamist
terrorists he says that he has become
increasingly concerned about
inflammatory political discourse that
has become far too common both at home
and abroad against Muslims and Islam
including proposals from various
quarters for blanket discrimination
against people on the basis of their
religion but his Target isn't just
Donald Trump's proposed temporary
moratorium on Muslim immigration it's
all speech that some Muslims might find
offensive
this has sweeping and ominous
implications Petraeus doesn't just
oppose what Trump now characterizes as
just a suggestion solely as a policy
measure he's saying that such proposals
shouldn't even be made for just to State
them is damaging in itself Petraeus says
the ramifications of such rhetoric could
be very harmful and Lasting he says they
will compound the already grave
terrorist danger to our citizens how
will they do that well you see Petraeus
says Those Who flirt with hate speech
against Muslims should realize they are
playing directly into the hands of
al-Qaeda and the Islamic State the
terrorists explicit hope has been to try
to provoke a clash of civilizations
telling Muslims that the United States
is at war with them and their religion
when Western politicians propose blanket
discrimination against Islam he says
they bolster the terrorists
propaganda now in saying all this
Petraeus does not offer any alternative
suggestions as to how Jihad terrorists
can be prevented from entering the US he
just doesn't like Trump's proposal and
what he terms hate speech against
Muslims in general because it will he
says enrage Muslims and make more of
them join the Jihad against the US so
the upshot of Petraeus argument is that
we must not say things to which Muslims
might object because this will just make
more of them become jihadis his
prescription for minimizing the Jihad
against the West is for the West to
practice self censorship against it in
order to avoid offending Muslims there
has been of course a comprehensive
effort to compel the West into doing
just that and it's going very well in
the wake of the Jihad attack on our Free
Speech event in Garland Texas last year
there were widespread condemnations of
our event for daring to provoke Muslims
after the Danish Muhammad cartoon riots
and the massacre of the Charlie hebdo
Muhammad cartoonists mainstream media
Outlets all over the West refused to
publish the cartoons in solidarity with
the victims and in defense of the
freedom of speech instead opting to
publish transparently hypocritical
explanations of how they were declining
to publish the cartoons out of respect
for Muslims and Islam the lesson of all
this is that one no less a figure than
General Petraeus has emed and is now
propagating himself Muslims don't like
when we say we should stop Muslim
immigration for a while and they join
the Jihad so we must stop saying it so
they won't join the Jihad this argument
will only encourage them to tell us
they're joining the Jihad because of
other things we do and say as well and
of course they're already doing that so
that we will stop doing and saying those
things also Petraeus is saying that in
the wake of violent intimidation by
Muslims the West's proper response is to
give those violent Muslims what they
want by conforming our speech to suit
them in reality this will only encourage
more violence intimidation if we take
Petraeus his advice it will not result
in less Jihad as he claims but in more
aggressive Muslim demands more rage and
more Revenge attacks Petraeus is giving
us a recipe for setting the world on
fire even more than it is now Lawrence
Summers who has served as president of
Harvard University Secretary of the
Treasury and economic adviser to Barack
Obama recently said a very similar thing
in his own Washington Post piece Summers
wrote a perception that the United
States is at war with Islam rather than
with radical elements within Islam is an
invitation to terrorism this of course
Echoes numerous similar statements made
by Barack Obama and others in the past
but there are several problems with it
one is that the radical elements within
Islam are not easily separable from
Islam while Muslim organizations all
over the world have issued condemnations
of the Islamic State Al-Qaeda and other
Jihad groups jihadis and Jihad
sympathizers still move freely in Muslim
communities few Muslim organizations
have pronounced takir upon that is
excommunicated the followers of Osama
bin Laden anir Al alaki Omar Abu Bakr Al
bagdadi Etc doctrines of warfare against
and subjugation of unbelievers can be
found among all mainstream Muslim sects
so how does Larry Summers or Obama or P
Petraeus or anyone else proposed to
distinguish the radical elements within
Islam from the rest for the purposes of
Prosecuting this war properly this is
the key question regarding Trump's
suggestion of a temporary moratorium on
Muslim immigration none of those who are
denouncing him for H having come up with
it have come up with any alternative
plan that's effective to keep jihadis
out while admitting Muslims also the
idea that as summer says a perception
that the United States is at war with
Islam rather than with radical elements
within Islam is an invitation to
terrorism rests upon the assumption that
Muslims who otherwise would have been
moderate will join Jihad Terror groups
if they don't like US policies regarding
Muslim immigration this place is the
onus for terrorism Upon Us rather than
on the jihadis themselves and suggests
that the way we can stop the Jihad is to
stop doing everything that Muslims
dislike in other words it's a call for
surrender and submission no thank you Dr
Summers no thank you General Petraeus
I'm Robert Spencer